那我这边就开始了,大家应该能看到我的PPT。今天呢,上半场给大家带来的话题呢,是Youtube88客户端的一个架构演进。那这个,这次呢,我分享的内容呢,会一个是结合我们现实的一个业务和架构的演进的路线,再一个呢,为了方便大家能把它转化为自己的内容,我也做了一些检要的模型和抽象,和一些开源方案的替换,希望大家能
吸取到一些思路同时也能在自己的这个团队的项目里面去落地好那我就开始嗯这一节这次分享的主要是四个部分的内容第一个呢就是强运营业务的动态性诉求强运营业务其实有有很多种啊一个就是我们的电商业务还有一个呢就是比如说类似于auto的这种偏展示类的其实都算是
强运营的一种业务那第二个部分呢就是端侧动态的这个容器架构的设计然后呢第三个部分就是页面大头其实就是那个所谓的叫低代码吧然后最后呢跟大家聊一聊这个成熟体系下端架构的下一步呃首先看第一个部分强运营业务的动态性诉求就是我们强运营业务这种一般情况还有哪一类的诉求呢第一个就是可能其实很多小伙伴都会遇到的就是
业务需求变化很快然后我们发板是无法满足的很多时候APP做大了以后对吧业务方很多然后比如说我们有一个月有两个版本但是有很多业务的变化它可能包括它有一些活动的上限这种它没法等发车对吧它就必须要动态的线上改来改去的所以会有这个需求变化很快发板不能满足第二就是促销这种页面很多现在动不动就是各种
各种类型的促销对吧不只是电商嘛你像那个本地生活什么都会有的那这种情况下呢页面有很多但是页面呢它的页面数量是层层这个几何数增加的但是我们的人一共就那么些人所以说如果说全部由自己来开发的话很显然这个开发资源是不够的就是来不及做第三个呢就是我们的这个页面的各种活动其实展示逻辑还是蛮复杂的然后也也涉及到很多个站的技术混合
因为现在移动端已经发展了这么多年了对吧大家也都知道我们现在各种各样的类型的技术都有比如说有web.js的有flutter的有各种各样的原生的还有各种跨平台的这些方案对吧所以说它都会涉及到这些页面所以说面临的是这个三个问题然后我们应该怎么样去满足这个
强运业务的动态性诉求怎么满足他们这种变来变去的这种诉求呢其实左边这个我这里面展示的就是我们1688APP的这个手艺啊其实如果说我们把它拆解成右边的这个页面就是如果说我们有一个容器的东西把它打底把整个底盘兜住然后中间所有的区块我们都用组件的方式去插拔展示那这样的话对于开发者来讲
它只需要动态的去更换替换组件如果说我们能做到这些组件动态上下线发版那么我们就可以满足大部分运营类业务的诉求包括活动页面包括搭建页面等等这一系列的诉求都可以满足其实简要的模型就这个怎么把这个页面拆掉拆成各种各样的组件其实拆组件这个问题
早在好几年前就有很多公司在做了包括美团这些都是有他们自己的这种组件的拆这种小组件的框架那么我这里面就讲一讲我们是怎么拆组件的那要想做到上面的这个效果首先是需要一个容器我们所称之为叫容器的东西那第二部分就跟大家聊一聊端侧容器架构的设计那首先看一看为什么需要端侧的容器容器的什么意思其实这个
概念并不是一个很新的概念它一开始我们都知道容器这个概念主要来于后段对吧Docker或者KBS那在端上的这个容器我们为什么要端的一个容器它是干嘛用的其实主要还是核心的下面这个三个点第一个就是提高研发效能从上面那个图里面我们也能看到对吧如果说我们有了容器以后理想状态下我们只需要动态的去迭代上面的小组件就可以满足整个页面的这个搭建
对吧 页面的发布包括动态的更新能满足各种各样业务的诉求这样的话可以提高我们整个的研发效能然后什么样的人都可以去开发我们这个组件这样的话就可以大大提升页面的发布的一个效率第二个就是保障体验和稳定性的下限就是在上面有这么灵活的一个能力的同时
很容易如果说不加以收拢或者是不加以控制的话很容易会导致一个问题就是你这个页面体验很差又很卡顿或者是在一些各种各样的机型上面尤其是安卓这种机型非常多的对吧设备上面中低端设备上面有可能就崩溃了或者是卡死了用户不能响应了等等那么容器有一个很大的作用也是为了保证这个体验很稳定一些下线其实这个对于我们
开发者来说其实大家在开发过程中都会用到一些框架对吧比如说iOS会用到afnetworking 安卓会用到okhtp那么我们为什么要用这些框架比如说以上面这个例子来讲我们为什么要用这些框架去完成我们这工作呢其实也是为了保障这个下线也就是说让不同的人不同水平的开发同学包括不管是新人对吧一年的新人也好
还是67年的老人也好那么写出来的代码执行出来的效果性能各方面都是差不多的这是为了整个都下限提高下限的第三个端容器的作用就是还有一个作用就是为了多个端之间做附用和扩展多个端的意思就是说其实我们1688这个部门它不只是做大家看到的那一个端我们还有好几个其他的端比如说我们有商家版
然后呢我们还有工业品类的读端就是面向一些细分的人群或者是面向商家的那么这一部分用户他们也会用到很多我们这些主客里面主客户端里面的一些包括一些页面包括一部分的页面一部分的能力那我们在一次性开发完成了以后如果说可以无缝的再多个端对吧跨端使用那也可以大大提升我们的研发效能
这是一个多端架构的问题所以说我们需要客户端做一个容器就是端容器那端容器要怎么做这里给大家聊一下我们整个当初的一个设计思路其实端容器要怎么做呢我们从顶上从这张图的上面往下看其实我们大概分析了一下我们自己端的一些核心的一些业务场景我们整体上大概就四类
一类就是我们非常核心的场景比如说首页搜索页面商品详情页面这种电商类非常核心的三个大场景这种我们要求是什么非常高的信任很好的体验不能阻断用户的浏览和下单的流程这是电商类最核心的第二个就是营销力的场景各种各样活动页面可能早上发一个下午就下线了
对吧包括有一些热点话题的时候也会有各种活动等等这一系列都是非常强的动态性的这个诉求的场景那还有一部分呢就是我们会外投到其他的各个端的就是这种是开放类的业务啊比如说我们会给商家做一些这个扩展能力的介入啊因为我们是1688上面是会有很多商家提供货源嘛然后呢他们会有一些能力就是需要用到小城区的能力给他们做一些各种各样的小插件小助手
这个主要是面向外头的那最后就是工具类的工具类的是什么东西呢比如说我们自己用的过程中的一些呃比如说直播间直播的一些工具啊包括是一些那个像收藏夹啊足迹啊这类的这种就是一面变得也不是很大用话不大的对吧这种相对来说比较稳定迭代没有那么快的就属于工具类其实我们主要是这四个大类然后那么从设计上来讲我们要容器它能
给我们提供什么样的能力呢其实容器的核心能力有一点就是要抹平上层的各种各样场景各种各样技术方案的一个差异性所以说它显然是非常需要一个通用的API揭露层的这个通用的API揭露层的意义是什么就是说我们上层的业务在容器中运行的时候其实我们是不用去关心容器内实现的我们只需要对接这个API就可以了我们对接上层的接口就可以了
这个就是一个通用层那么在容器层我们要满足各种各样场景的一个正常的投放对吧使用对吧包括那些增量的能力所以说我们需要容器提供的这几个这一共有8个能力一个就是第一个就是插件就是我们容器里面肯定会有各种各样的插件供右方调用的第二个就是事件这两个肯定是最最核心的能力了
第三个调度是什么的就说我们这个容器比如说在展示不同类型页面的时候我们有一个调度优先级和调度权重的可能就说我是一个页面上面其实大家看到一个页面它可能不只是一个页面它里面可能还有一些小扶层就是那种可以拖拽的小扶标或者是可能有一些小弹窗之类的这种都是需要调度的然后就是交互我这个页面用户要滑动要点击然后可能会有一些
红包它要抢一下之类的这种就是一些交货然后就是我们对于资源数据统计这一侧也是有统一的能力提供的一个就是肯定要有这个买点做线上报表的资源的这块的话尤其是对于像S5X这种场景我们会有资源的预埋预推这些能力然后数据中心我们做用户的各种各样的数据分析我们这个是给用户运营提供一个基础的
还有就是核心的一些GS的引擎来做一些啊这种脚本化的事情那最后呢最底下其实就是对接我们的数据平台数据平台做什么事情呢就是分析对吧就是做各种各样数据分析的比如说我们可以根据人群来分析根据人群来去投放等等一系列包括我们的这个这个业务发出去的以后对吧性能情况啊用户体验啊转化率啊达标率啊等等这一系列都需要数据平台去做对接
所以说整体上其实我们对于现在的一个状况分析啊一个端的容器大概它的整体上思路就是这样的那怎么样去真正去实现一个端的容器呢这张图呢就是这张图相对来说这个这个内容比较多我我慢慢慢慢讲呃就是首先是要有一个我们自己的一个容器的架构的
那么容器怎么去实现这个容器这一层第二个就是能力标准化能力标准化意味着什么呢就是我们要有标准的协议和标准的工作流程这样的话才能真正对上母平差异对于上层不管是他们排查问题也好揭露也好使用能力也好都是标准的这是一个标准化流程所以先看中间这个图中间这个图就是我们整个容器的架构材
容器架构最底下我们对接的一个是数据平台一个是搭建平台搭建平台后面会跟大家讲就是我们低代码这一块然后上层是容器网关核心我们看容器基础能力这一块其实就是刚才上一张图的这些能力的一个扩展插件事件包含了什么然后调度包含了什么我们有各种各样的动态的任务下发这个其实是
对于不同用户场景运营这一块比较有效果然后有各种各样的交互的能力买点还有JS的运行环境数据的处理和融灾资源的下载缓存和预推这就是我们基础能力的构建这一部分人这就是容器内的能力的构建上层不管是用什么方式什么技术占据适配那么核心的底层能力都是这些都是统一的
然后中间层API这层就是我们说的那个统一API这层其实我们是用协议化驱动的核心就是协议协议主要包含了插件协议事件协议调度协议和交互协议这四个大类插件协议呢就是很简单就是容器调用业务的这个能力然后事件协议呢就是容器之间这个通信的能力因为我们一个页面可能会有不同的容器会有几个容器叠在一起也有可能说我容器之间对吧跳页了
这种也需要有些数据的通信这就是容器建造一个通信的能力还有就是调度调度就是我刚才说的有各种各样任务的优先级调配等等包括面向不同的人群做不同的触发这个是调度能力然后最后就是交互的这个这个协议交互的协议就是我们去触发容器的交互反馈那这四个大的这个协议那么对上层适配来讲呢其实就是全都面向协议来进行开发了
对上层的实现发展来说我是不关心容器内部具体是怎么操作的我只关心协议我的协议有没有正确配对通过协议来触发容器的各种各样的动作对上层渲染这一部分其实我们就有很多很多的渲染方案了正常的就是最原生的大家这个native就是我们写UI的这种方式正常开发然后这里面地差就是
这个集团的一个动态化的一个方案就是动态化就native的一个动态化的方案就是卡片类的然后呢这个这上面呢还有就是h5wx的吧然后就小工具啊那这上面对应的其实也是有各种各样的语言啊比如说java和oc啊然后包括这个xml的这种类似于脚本语言啊json啊然后包括像前端的这种rax等等那么对于这个API这一层呢他们直接调用的话呢都是有一层适配的比如说像这个bridge啊
像model 像flutter 和channel 等等包括native download 和event这种就是一个主要就是为了对上抹平差异的适配 适配这个协议来做的然后这个就是整个容器的架构这个看起来东西很多 其实不复杂其实核心就是如果说我们把基础的能力收拢好然后API的协议这一层 关键是这个地方这个地方如果能定义好
然后再做好上升四配其实最终我们的改动不是容器本身而是上层业务容器是一个处于会处于一个基本稳定的状态然后就是这个标准的工作流标准工作流的话呢这个很简单这个我是抽象了一个就是比较简单的模型出来有正常情况下我们进了一个页面它可能会有各种各样的容器对吧然后容器会启动启动了以后呢它首先会做协议的加载
那协理家在里面其实就包含了我们这些协议啊这就是我们当前这个容器那么两个大类呢一个就是我们这个容器到底有哪些组件就是大家看到了这个页面上面有哪些组件这个首先要说明的嘛第二就是我的这些组件里面都展示什么数据其实这就是最大的两类然后呢这两个核心的数据有了以后其实理论上讲我们就可以进行页面的渲染了嘛那对于一个页面来讲有UI有数据它就是一个页面了嘛
就是可以进行确认然后确认完了之后进行一个事件的交互这个其实就是从容器层面来看的一个能力的一个标准化的一个能力所有的容器它运行都是这样的不管是一个像页面级的能跳页面的这种页面级还是页面内部的浮层弹窗 卡片等等它都是这个逻辑然后
然后就是刚才那个说到的就是我们端容器的第三个目标第一个目标就是为了那个我们再看一下第一个目标就是为了这个提高研发效能对吧然后第二个目标就是为了保证体验恨稳定性下限对吧这个其实跟容器的架构有关系还有跟容器上层的这个设计有关系就是我们用什么方案其实也可以说我们也不一定说这些方案都需要用我们可能只是用其中的一到两种这种动态性比较强的方案
就OK就可以满足绝大部分诉求了那第三个部分就是我们跨端的一个附用这个是我们我们这里会遇到了一个问题就是刚才会说我们不只是主客主客户端一个端我们还有一些细粉品类的端比如说工业品类然后我们还有面向商家的端1688的商家吧那这种情况下呢我们就需要很多一些基础类的业务尤其是基础类的业务我们是多个端
要跨端附用的然后上层的业务呢其实我们也是有很多是直接拿过来就是比如说可能它的那个皮肤不一样对吧改一改样式然后它里面的内容可能触发交互不太一样但实际上它的核心元素包括一些核心的数据可能也只是接口的参数不一样但是返回的数据的格式什么都是一样的那对于一个UI展示来讲其实我们这个UI是可以拿来附用的不需要在额外的再去开发很多做一点适配
那这个就是多端附用的一个架构它是一个机遇容器的一个多端附用架构那首先有一个业务能力的打底啊就是有基础库对吧然后还有就是业务能力的结偶那么这样的话容器可以向下调用各种各样的这个业务的能力嘛然后就是刚才我们讲到的容器这层那容器这层可以包含很多种啊其实我这里列的会比较多其实如果说呃做用减化模型来做的话我们其实如果说只要支持一种就可以了
这个简化模型一会会跟大家讲这里大家就理解就是说我们上面的构建的容器的架构就在容器的这一层就OK了然后在容器上面我们承载各种各样的业务的模块我这里淋漓了一些就是我们自己端淋的一些业务的模块比如说搜索这个是我们非常核心的一个模块推荐然后商品收藏夹
直播啊这个会员消息这一类的像而言我们很多模块都是在首页就会展示的那么这些是我们的业务模块那这些模块呢其实是在不同的页面里面它都会有的比如说我们的首页有推荐然后我们工作台那个页面也有推荐对吧这就是业务模块在不同页面之间它都会有一些平一些重复出现或者一些组合出现的那么上层的页面里面其实就是这里我们我列了一下像首页啊这个这个
进货单其实就是向淘宝里面的那个叫博物车啊然后商品详情页面直播包括我们的各种就登录啊恰恰就是聊天的就是那个大家跟商家直接沟通的啊聊天页面然后就是品类啊这个能看到品各种各样的品类找东西的那其实从业务模块到这个页面的这个这个支撑来说其实就是上层的业务要有各种各样的定制化嘛
然后我们中间业务模块是要做跨端复用的那么他们是怎么复用其实核心就是各种各样的小组件那我们的推荐模块呢其实也是容器里面就包含了几种类型的卡片这种小组件来来来构建的那这个对于Android来讲呢可能就是像RecycleView这种里面放了几个不同的item减换下来就是这个样子包括其他的也是只不过可能就是呃你可以这么理解就是说
然后里面各种各样的item它的itemtype不一样而已这样构建的这么一个页面最简单的来讲模型就是这个样子所以说这就是一个在容器的基础上我们可以比较低成本的做到一个多端复用的一个架构那么基于这套架构其实我们之前去开一些新的端的时候速度是非常快的就是假设我们现在
基于我们的主客户端假如我们再去开一个类似的电商端比如说我们卖其他的东西卖其他的西粉品类那可能一两个星期我们整个端就能建起来就直接能发布了这个是在一开始我们只有主客户端后面开了工业品类以后是经历过这个实践的那效果也给大家看一下其实这里我就就列举了我们的主客户端我们主客户端就叫阿里巴巴客户端名字就是阿里巴巴我们这个部门叫1688
就网页也叫阿里巴巴但是其实我们这个客户单的名字就叫阿里巴巴然后还有看就是右边我们是右边我截了图是那个我们的公园品这个细分品类的客户单大家左边右边其实你咋一看它可能是两种类型的APP对吧但它其实很多功能各种方面都是都是复用的这里面呢这两个一个是我列举的一个手页一个工作台工作台就是那个APP右下角点了个我的那个Tab
展示的东西然后这个工作台呢其实这里大家看到的是买家的如果你是商家的话呢你看到的界面还不一样啊包括还有一些专业版各种各样的类型的那么这种情况下其实我们做到了我这里写的90%其实不止啊就是至少也在95%以上模块都是复用的那么是直接可能拉过来换个皮肤
或者是甚至皮肤都不用换就头不同的资源头不同的数据啊他就能展示成不同的样子了就是可能看出来完全就是不同的端了因为我们的页面是完就是完全靠搭建靠各种拼接组合成的这个东西也是不需要自己开发的直接线上就能改就是类似于这个拖拽这么一个形式如果说大家有用过那个那个那个微软的那个那个ID叫visual C6对吧你最开始用cxr不写
以外的话其实它最开始也是拖拽了各种各样的拖拽就把这个音乐拖出来就是类似我们也是类似这样一个东西这是一个效果的展示然后这里跟大家上面说了一些可能有同学没有特别理解所以说我这里面重新跟大家聊一下整个集结模型如果说我们想实现一个耳容器这么一个东西的话端容器这么一个东西的话那么我们选用什么样的方案
那么最简单的来说也包括我也比较建议要大家去采用基于DSL的这个Native增强也就是Native Plus这种方案这种方案其实并不是个多么新的方案如果说大家网上搜一搜的话可能1718年就有人在用这个方案做东西了它的好处是什么呢一个是扩展性高再一个第二就是接近Native的性能
除了这个接口的解析下方数据解析数据以外就就就没有什么别的损耗了就直接那些我去炫耳嘛然后第三个呢就是他没有额外的类似于引擎的东西像flag有个有个引擎对吧GS的话我们要有一个也需要有个GS call或者是v8对吧那这个就是我们正常自己的内举他没有什么额外的引擎引路所以说对这个整个包的体积没有什么影响然后呢
基于DSL的内地增强其实就是核心就在DSL那么DSL我们完全下发了以后就有灵活的动态布局能力然后就是学习迁移和开发维护的成本都很低因为开发这个东西你也不需要很高的成本这个SDK也不会很大然后假设我们是举个例子就是我们把正常情况
RS同学可能如果用oc写的话呢我们写UI布局很爽用storyboard对吧都是用那个oc的代码把这个布局 add上去的那对于安卓同学来讲可能会更有体会啊安卓同学的话呢大家最开始写布局肯定是用xml嘛那个编辑器然后xml的布局一个一个自己自己写上去那如果说我们把xml布局的这个能力放成假设我有一个web IDE让你在上面
同样的你只是把你布局的页面拖到上面去写有包括代码提示 包括预览我都给你做起来然后你把XML写好了之后动态下发下来然后再端上解析运行这样的话其实学习和前移开发成本是很低的所以极简模型的话我推荐大家用这种基于DSI的Native增强去做动态化容器的方案选型然后我列了一些开源方案的参考
基于这个DSL的话呢首先我们肯定要有一个布局方案就是我们这个方案到底要怎么布局布局方案的话其实业界双端统一用的最多的就是flexbox这种方案这也是一种类似于这个就是从前端眼睛过来的一个方案flexbox本身是从前端那边眼睛过来的一个方案那这个在双端的都比较成熟了最出名的就是facebook有点这个引擎然后它是快平台的
它上层也封装了两个方案一个是面向OS的Component Kit还有一个是面向Android Little这两个方案这个就是GUGuide做的Flexbox的布局引擎还有一个就是Flexbox Layout这个是指面向Android的其实根本上来讲都是Flexbox你甚至可以把上面的Component Kit和Flexbox Layout在双端组合一起去使用通过这种Flexbox的这种方式去下发
然后再端上去做这个布局然后就是对于容器这块呢我列了这两个项目其实也更新的不长了上面这个就是天猫天猫还是淘宝以前开源的一个叫七桥版核心就是基于各种UsocView对吧各种各种操作嘛把你的这个这个页面组合拼接搭建下来然后你的组件可以通过这个比如说xml这种协议或者是json的协议去下发第二个就是
第二个是面向 iOS 的然后他也是用 JSON 布局去下发他说他号称说是可以用 JSON 直接写把 UI 写出来他也是用 JSON其实就是描述一个协议然后把这个协议下发给端上的 SDK 去执行然后渲染出来一个 native 的页面去解析解析完了就拿到相应的布局去渲染就这种动态的就是 DSL native plus 的方案呢灵活对吧成本也低然后开发
开发的城门眼帝,维护城门眼帝,迁移学习城门眼帝但是它有一个缺点缺点就是可能你如果说你要用到一些除了我内体无端预埋的组件之外的组件这种就需要根本了比如说我举个简单的例子可能我一开始讲是我在老版本的APP上我没有在端上实现这个轮波图这么一个组件
那如果说我后面需要实现轮波图的话我在端上预买一个native的这个原神组件以后我在上层DSR去用这个标签的时候那老版本是没法生效的就是有这一个缺陷这个就是急减模型和看源方案的参考关于这块的话大家有什么问题也可以直接提啊这个这种抽象出来应该相对来说就比较好理解了那这这个方案呢其实在那个
阿里巴巴就是比较代表性的就是集团的Dynamic差这个如果大家关注淘宝的技术公众号的话他们会有之前又会有一系列的讲解它根本上其实就是一个基于DSI的Native增强方案只不过基于这个方案它做了各种各样的比如说一些优化呀一些这个完善对吧一方案的核心核心原理明白了之后但你真正线上大面积使用的时候肯定不只是实现一个靠就完事了嘛
你肯定要实现推套的一系列的东西对吧来支撑你线上的各种类型的业务包括一些定制包括一些稳定性等等一系列的东西但是核心原理就是这个这个也是我们用的最多的其实我们大家看到1688APP就是我们主客户端这个APP你打开看到首页搜索还有商品详情其实我们都是基于Dynamic China就是DSL的Netto增强的这种方案去搭建出来的
这个很好用啊然后前面在讲容器的时候也各种提到这个这个这个搭建嘛那搭建是什么意思就是页面的这个搭建头放那其实我们说这个页面的搭头呢其实就是地带码lowcode或者是procode那这个地带码这个概念在在前端其实可能呃非常常见了或者是尤其是这种前端在面向壁端的比如说我们做那个
管理系统后台管理系统之类的这种页面其实都是托托载载已经有很完善的方案了托载一个组件直接发出去完事了对吧那也包括那个大家做一些那种运营内的s5啊就是有什么一起秀这种方案它其实都是这种思想就是我把几个成型的模板啊组件啊托一托外然后就组成的页面就发布用户就可以去点击使用交互了那它的特点呢就是成本很低
然后不需要发版我随时上线,随时下线风险都会可控的整体开发成本小,风险也很少啊,地插不是Visual View扩展出来的你可以理解为它就是那个把安卓端的XML放到云端去写了给你一个Web IDE然后你你去写一个安卓上面一模一样的XML布局动态下发下来用安卓的那套解析的流程把它解成那些组件把层级解出来再做个拍屏差不多就是这个样子嗯
搭建平台如果说我们要做一个页面搭投这么一个能力的话就是要有搭建投放这个能力的话我们肯定要有平台对吧我们有一个页面要操作嘛那么这个平台要怎么去做它的核心的能力要有哪些呢这个就是我写了一个搭建平台的转化力是RSA一样RSA也是一样的只不过就是把这套那个就是比如说我假设Android用XMR号我把这个代码
Oc实现一遍的就是IOS的模型就出来了对吧然后对于搭建平台来讲的话它的核心减化流程就是首先我们要有物料就是叫组件因为我们能搭出来一个页面的话前提是要有各种各样的组件所以说我们需要有组件发布这个是前置流程就是我们有一个组件池大家写好的组件以后会发布到这个池子里面去供业务方业务同学去选用这是一个前提
然后就是我们要创建出一个页面来我们在平台上面搭建首先要New出来一个页面白板然后我们就要开始做组件的编辑了这个组件的编辑其实就是一个托转但是我们的这个平台不是托转它上面会有一个加号你往里面添组件也会有个减号你可以往这组件删掉然后我们把组件加进了以后可以做这么几种大的类型的编辑一个是容器的层级比如说我当前的页面里含有
一个主的页面然后呢底下还有几个tab然后这个tab就是可以点击里面有紫页面这种会有页面的嵌套对吧然后还有就是说像我们现在主端的首页这种页面来说我们有这个这个上面的这个首页上面的一些单个组件然后我们还有推荐嘛像推荐这种的话它就是一个自己内就自己内门里面套了一层套了一层容器你可以理解为套了一个luxag view啊luxag view嵌套了
那么这个就是组建编辑的话首先我们要把层级给它编辑出来它放置在什么层级下面去那第二个就是数据配置这个很关键嘛我们有了组建有了页面以后有了这个UI以后我们要有数据对吧那数据哪里来呢那数据其实就是两种一种就是说我们这个数据有在接口里面内置了就是我们整个容器的页面下发协议的时候内置了那我们把这个数据就local的写进去那第二个就是说我们在下发的协议之后
其实对于这个组件来讲我们数据没有内置而是它还要去请求一个接口把接口的数据回来再跟UI去做绑定对吧那就是属于叫动态数据这就是我们的一个数据配置那第三个就是扩展信息我这里面只说扩展信息其实这里面内景有很多比如说我扩展信息有这个页面的当前的各种皮肤对吧然后呢有一些可能有一些ABR
这个这个这个这个能力包括一些那个性能优化的能力啊包括买点啊各个方面的这都属于扩展信息就是除了上面两层之外其他都是扩展信息这个其实如果说大家现在要做一个这个这个这个搭建平台的话你扩展信息这块其实可以很简单这个也是慢慢堆叠起来的随着义务复杂叠带各个方面啊在这个你可以把它理解为一个大阶层里面的一个小字段慢慢慢慢慢慢把这个小字段吩咐堆叠出来
这就是组件编辑的话我们是最重要的三个要素其中最核心的就是容器的层级就是这个页面当前的那个层这个组件当前在页面上的那个层级然后第二个就是数据哪里来然后就是页面的插件对于页面维度我们可能会做AB做数据统计那这里面是会在页面维度而不是组件维度去内置一些插件过来的这是页面的插件然后我们就可以预览嘛预览就是
我们可以扫码生成了这个组件以后它就出来一个二维码然后扫一下码在APP上就会有一个预览的页面让你去预览你这个组件渲染出来到底找什么样子对吧是否符合你的这个要求比如说什么間距背景色了居中什么左右上下的对吧这种楼层包括有没有你可能会有一些
要求比如说我要铺步流展式等等你在发布之前在真正你运行之前都是可以进行预览观看的最后就是把这个页面发布掉这个就发布了以后我们在端上其实想去渲染一个页面很简单最简单的就是New一个VC或者是一个Activity然后用我们容器的SDK的入口Incense实力去Render一个UIL
然后把这个发布了之后下这个就产生的这个URL丢进去就OK了就什么也不用干了他自己就会把这个页面渲染出来该请求请求该渲染然后该到底什么的都有然后包括数据分析买点自动化的这些都有的就OK了然后这个是我们自己内部的搭建平台天搭这里我引调了一些那个马塞克的一些核心信息就是一些
不好展示的信息然后给大家看一下我们内部大概是什么样子啊就是左边其实这个页面也也比较简单对吧你看中间有大块的空白这个页面里面的元素不会很多然后最左边的就是我们的这个组件啊各种各样的组件这这里是我以首页为例啊就是啊我们这个组件有都都有各种方法banner啊门洞啊什么新人然后会员这些啊
这些各种各样的组件都在左边然后你看每一个组件其实它上面都有一个基准的容器的然后在底下的推荐的它还是把这些组件全部放在一个容器就是我们组件可以容器之间并列然后也可以把这些组件渲染在一个容器里面这些都是可以的左边就是动态组件然后这些组件你看其实可能我们左边有十几二十几个组件但是真正渲染出来可能可能你看到的只有其中一部分那这个是因为我们
在组件上面有各种各样的数据的配置资源的配置就说右边这一部分对吧我们有这个比如说皮肤氛围每次移到大醋这个就开始红了就开始有这种整个APP你会发现很喜庆对吧这个就是氛围下发配置投放的然后就是我们动态的数据员然后我们这个投放还可以有这个台期就是
比如说什么这一周我头发个蓝色然后下一周就自动给它变成红色等等这一系列都是你运营位一次性配好了以后就不需要管了它到时间它就自动出发了它下发的时候就不一样了然后你一个APP页面就不一样了然后中间其实就是你一个一个组件拖起来的页面那这个页面其实你从这个上面的图片预览这个图片预览你看到的是所有组件的集合它并不是真正炫出来的样子
然后这个右上角应该是还有一个预览的小按钮大家应该能看到我右边有一个就是发布上线这个地方左边有个预览的小按钮这个预览就是说我可以用砖码来看在我们客户端上当前版本的客户端上道理宣言出来找什么样子因为有一些组件它需要有登录有一些组件它是低版本才会有然后高版本没有或者是高版本有低版本没有就是有各种各样的限制所以说你是需要
我们需要一般情况下就需要扫码自己预览看一下到底长什么样子然后就是这个组建的这个配置好了之后就可以发布了发布了以后其实我们端上就就直接这个动态颜面就形成了那这一套呢也不需要发版然后呢我们的很多组建的开发其实都不是政治员工都是外包啊单个组建的变来变去其实都是外包来做的都不需要政治员工去投投人呢就大幅度提升业发项目
然后这个下发了以后怎么变成一个页面啊?其实协议到底是什么意思?那真正对于我们下发平台下发的这个对对对,有点像这个店铺装修这个意思啊,其实差不多,差不多。然后核心思路就是我们协议对于这个搭建平台来说我们协议核心就四个大的部分,一个是布局的结构就是层级,一个是层级,容器的类型,比如说有些是需要瀑布流的。
有些就是单个的有些需要横排的,有些需要树排的这个不同容器的类型不一样然后第二种就是组件我们有多少个组件往上拖嘛然后这个就是布局结构第二个就是描述组件保定的数据这个刚才我给大家也提到了一部分就是静态数据合在大接口里面一起下巴的就是LOCAL的数据
这种是你自己写好就写一个阶层进取OK了那第二个呢就是动态数据员动态数据员呢就是你看我们上面这个这个配置的动态数据员资源位嘛就写了一个那这就是我们有各种各样的动态数据员的配置那这个其实你你把它简化掉那你配置的其实你可以理解为下方就是个接口然后当你当你在解析协议的数据这一个部分的时候
你把这个协议看成一个大的接审你在解析协议数据这个部分的时候呢你解析到它是一个Dynamic的数据的时候它里面下发的其实就是一个接口加参数然后你直接去请求就完了请求过来的数据直接渲染就OK了就拿到数据多了一步请求第三个是组件的模板那模板的话呢就是我们如果是用DSL加这个Native的话就是Native Plus这种方案的模型来做的话呢就是
比如说用XML这种方式下发或者说我直接用階层下发也可以都可以你只要能描述清楚你你当前这个组件就ok了比如说上面有几个页面什么有什么recycle view料料的什么txt view这些你的描述清楚就ok然后最后就是组件的样式组件的样式呢就是比如说有背景啊透明度啊前后间隔啊等等大家平时经常用到的就是调来调去的就是样式
主要是这四个大的类型的数据然后呢这一个大杰森对吧协议请求把这个大的协议下发下来以后呢交给容器他就会按照我们的这个协议的标准通过他标准化的流程去解析布局数据模板和样式最终组合确认成一个页面大杰森会不会影响响应啊我我理解你的意思就是说大杰森会不会有这个比如说包体过大然后这个
这个这个这个这个导致接口慢对吧这种情况如果说是完全一个很大的json下发肯定会有的那这里面呢就是一个是你有了这个大json以后首先你有一部分的协议一部分的数据是可以精简的再呢就是我们我们自己其实真实的容器存呢这是一个默认的流程啊我们真实的容器存还提供了一些定制化的这个入口那定制化的入口呢就是我可以把这里面的这里面的一部分数据拆到其他
就是不是在一个接口里面全部下发而是可以通过比如说缓存比如说拼接各种形式最终组装在一起去渲染就这样的话呢现在会更好其实我们的这个核心的三个页面就是首页搜索和相挺相勤都是基于容器在上层做了业务定制的就是我们容器定制化了这个接口也设标准化了定制啊定制化了接口让他们去干预这种默认的行为而从而达到一个优化的效果
这个也是有的RS的动态其实你如果说就是一个XMR或者是JSON下发协议那我下发一个协议里面印设成什么这个组件这种就是动态发的方案其实这个不叫热更新它并不是下发一个什么比如说像安卓下发可执行代码里不是像GSPatch这种需要有个引擎去跑只是结构返回的数据不一样展示的页面不一样不太一样然后然后
数据源的数据结构其实它是跟页面的模板匹配的比如说我的页面模板里面接吻对吧我一个页面比如说假设我最简单举个例子TaxView然后它有一个Tax的这么一个属性它就显示什么文字对吧然后它这个Tax属性我如果是动态数据的话我肯定不可能写死所以说我肯定会有一个站位
比如说我这个站位呢是我即将返回了json里面的data里面的tax这个字段那这是要提前约定好的所以说当我下发的就是我下发的这个组件模板里面发下来它其实解析出来它是一个站位符然后它要等到数据员回来了以后再从对应的层级和位置中解析出这个组件就解析出这个具体的数据最后填充上去啊这个才是组合出一个真正的页面
一个页面很有很多UI引擎,其实我们这个不是引擎,其实你根本上就是内提无线人,只不过是用了各种数据动态下发的方案去引导内提无线人,其实就跟你本地,你本地让一个比如说你Android用一个Activity写一个这个页面出来你用XML去写对吧,那你只是少了对于我们来说你只是少了一个接口下发这个XML过程,本质上讲是一样的。
交互的其实点击跳转页面是有内置的对我们有内置的行为你可以在内置的事件里面写好就可以帮你自动出发了这种整体的项目有没有开源的其实没有所以说我上面的开源的方方就是开源的这个推荐里面也只是写了一些布局方案和容器的这个你可以作为参考但是这种完整的方案是没有的如果下班的app里面没有组件就不展示了然后
最后跟大家聊一下就是整个成熟体系下端价格的下一步成熟体系什么意思就是大家其实做客户端也知道这么多年了然后客户端也像后端一样它的基础方案已经非常非常成熟了非常非常成熟了以后呢那么我们下一步做什么呢其实我这里列了一些第一个就是价格收敛做减法刚才大家也提到了有人问就是这个
事件有一部分是端上郁埋标准我看有人问怎么处理事件事件有一部分是端上郁埋写好了这一部分就是可以直接调用基本的点击跳转什么然后其他的也可以在端上去做扩展那如果说在端上做扩展的话就需要根本发布就会有版本问题就是有一些事件只能在某个版本之上才支持这样的这是我之前提到的这种DSL加Native Glass的方式它的一个缺陷
然后这里继续讲这个端架构的下一步第一个其实就是做整个架构收敛做减法架构收敛做减法呢就是很简单啊就是我们比如说像刚才大家可能有问到比如说我因为里面有各种各样UI引擎烂七八糟全部堆在一起性能会不会不好会肯定会所以说我们要把它收敛起来做核心的标准化然后有些同类型的方案全部干掉做减法
方案其实我们的架构越收敛方案越单一一种类型的方案越单一我们这个稳定性性能体验都会有都会有一个提升这是一个基础第二个呢就是在第一个点之上架构白河化架构白河化呢就是说我在上层假设我就就比如说我我们安卓开发同学来说啊那个UI确认对你来说其实就是白河化的你只要是自定义一个view对吧你肯定需要实现
layout,measure和draw这三个最核心的函数对吧你只要把这三个实现好了你的view一定会很好那这个就是一个白核化的基础这个就是你的流程对你来说透明的其他你不需要过度的关心只需要关心这三个函数就可以了这个就是价格白核化对于我们容器来说也是核心流程一共就这么几个可能三五个流程你实现好了就ok了然后可观测可度量这个概念其实
我解释一下这个概念也不是一个夺心的概念这个概念最开始是从远远伸后段远远伸过来的可观测可督良什么意思就是说我们正常情况下大家肯定会知道做监控对吧我有个问题报警Crash怎么的监控它有一个最大的问题它都是被动感知就是当我感知到这个问题的时候问题已经发生了我是要事后修补
而且我还没把那么快的修补我要根本下一个版本修补等等一系列的问题不一定能热更新修补那这个是监控监控看的是最表面的问题也是最严重的问题被动发现监控和告警那官司和度量呢就是说我们基于日治的一个串联链路的一个串联架构白核化加日治加数据的一些指标那我们这些东西串联起来
那最终就是它就会形成一个叫观测这么一个这么一个平台我可以构建一个观测平台那么我在这个观测上面可以看什么东西呢比如说我可以看我这个页面的一些达标率啊我可以自己订一些数据标出来吗我需要看的比如达标率啊我的品质打分啊pspt分啊我们这中中低端基不同的用户对吧不同类型的用户都是可以做分离观测做度量
比如说我针对不同类型的业命我关注的不一样那么我观测的东西又不一样那观测可以看到什么东西它是可以看到除了监控之外更下一层的比如说一些排错对吧一些依赖关系在线调试等等等等这个大家可以这个是我后面11月份会再讲这个观测这个东西这个后面大家可以在网上所以说资料其实概念不新
很多只是我们把这个概念拿过来在端上去做落地第三个就是多端的一致性多端一致性的就是说当这个我据我说一下就是说当你的客户端就是你的这个APP逻辑足够复杂了以后你一定会面临一个问题就是当出现一个问题的时候很容易出现AndroidOS或者是其他的端之间行为不同
就是你兜底都不好兜就是比如说可能有一个组建安卓展示ROS不展示然后ROS展示安卓不展示这种就不好排查所以说当你的业务足够复杂的以后是需要多段一致性的这个一致性可以是强一致也可以弱一致那弱一致呢就说我们双端不同的实现对吧我在不同的实现上做到逻辑一致然后并且可以做到交叉review我这里写到了Cautely和Swift这两个语言它的特点就是长得特别特别像
然后完全可以交叉review你让安卓去看oc其实很难对吧oc那个语言其实我也看不懂所以如果是用swift的话那就简单了我们用callable用swift的这种代码是可以大部分都是可以直接交叉review的这个淘宝也这么干也有一部分是这么干的那你要想搞得更强一致来说呢
就可以用刚才就弹幕也提到了KMM就是Codling Platform这方案就是Codling原本身的特性去做强一致的解决就是说我用一套Codling代码写好了逻辑写好了这部分逻辑以后我编一层不同平台的产物直接调用运行那这就是强一致型因为代码是一样的然后
你calculate multiple form的这个其实大家最近可以搜一下那个像QCAN XMET包括GMTCL对这从去年开始已经有去年今年尤其是今年今年有比较多的老师会去在这种会议上做calculate multiple form的分享大家可以感兴趣可以去关注一下然后第四个就是我们从架构面向解决就是架构引进成一个解决方案
那我们架构比如说我搞了一个sdk出来的我说我这是架构的一环但是针对不同的上层的场景比如说我的搜索场景 首页场景 下单场景 商品场景这种各种各样的场景光有一个架构一个或者某一个sdk它是不够的它需要形成一个解决方案
就比如说我们用户运营这个场景我需要有用户运营的能力那么可能我需要有在用户链路上去做感知在用户浏览APP的同时不同的情况下去看它的这个比如说它在这个页面上面停留了很久我可能给它谈个什么穿把它挽留一下或者给它发个红包等等这其实就是从架构组合成解决方案它不只是一两个SDK的解决问题而是结合具体的场景
把我们的核心能力进行有机组合而做的方案包括从这个包括性能方案也是就是去结合具体的场景去做定制和解决就是我们现在其实发展了这么多年啊你很难说我拿到一个sdk我突然发现了它里面有一个方法啊写的不好然后很慢很慢然后我把这一个方法优化了然后我一下子整个APP就提升就起飞这个不大可能
现在去做这种体验优化的话呢往往是需要集合场景去做域内的解决方案的就是面向不同的场景做不同的解决方案去做把一些我们的核心的原子还能去做组合最终提升在这个场景下的一些体验指标或者是一些数据指标业务指标这就解决方案然后第五个呢就是横伙的话题就把元宇宙那现在其实
我们也都知道淘宝也成立了Mate这个部门吧大家在外面这个也都能看到包括德务之前也分享过最近的像AXA Meet QCon都有这类似圆影周的这种话题其实在端上其实现在大家更多的是关注圆影周里面的新交互这个环节也就是像AR VR像自己有Pico这种
然后像这个电商类的APP很多就是AR这个比如说什么试装试协啊画画口红啊包括像SOW这种就用交友的APP的这种捏脸就是数字人像等等这这个呢这部分呢其实就是对于客户端来讲呢你说它是个机会呢也算了吧就是
你也是可以往这个方面去转型的因为现在其实如果说单看客户端端本身来讲确实已经很成熟了就像是这个这么多年的佳乱一样现在这么多年佳乱的很多人他并没有那么关心中间念了因为太成熟了他可能看了就上面的领域模型数据分析滴滴滴对吧然后去做更多样的分析做平台去达到去组合解决方案去做这个场景拿结果的吗
然后端上如果大家对这个东西感兴趣的话也可以往这个方面靠一靠就是说这种新交互新的这种交互智能交互结合这个端上的AI端上的智能去做这个模型的你和去做3DAR确认这也是一个其实各个厂都在探索的一个方向吧也是最近比较火热的一个方向好然后我这个分享就到这里